hey David when it comes to coronavirus
are we the only country smearing doctors
who are trying to save lives like dr.
Anthony Fuji it's a good question
Anthony Fuji has been smeared widely by
the coronavirus protestors who have been
saying for more than a month now we've
got to open it up we never should have
closed it down we saw a chance of fire
pouchy at a number of different protests
we more recently I covered this earlier
in the week we saw signs that say hang
foul Chi and hang Bill Gates as well but
the truth is that we are not the only
country where doctors have been targeted
the thing is in most of the other places
where we see it the doctors are being
targeted by the state not by random
protesters so I'll give you some
examples we know that early very early
in the corona virus outbreak in China
there were doctors who were starting to
see the spread of corona virus and they
were talking about it and we have a
number of reports that law enforcement
authorities showed up at the homes of
some of these Chinese doctors and said
you've got to stop talking about this
this is you you can't keep talking about
this spreading virus which at the time
we knew very little about and hadn't
really identified this was in late 2019
so certainly we've seen antagonism of
doctors in China the difference is it's
not coming from random protesters it's
not coming from media in the same way
maybe state media but we did see law
enforcement antagonized doctors in
Russia we have a number of reports of
doctors who were working on corona virus
and speaking about corona virus who fell
out of windows now I don't want to say
more than what we know it sounds weird
to me it's like those stories of hey
someone fell on a knife ten times okay
well what do you mean they fell on a
knife ten times there are reports of
multiple Russian doctors that were
making public statements about
coronavirus who fell out of windows and
died I'm not going to say any more
because we don't know anymore but my
point is I am not aware
of the loud public campaigns against
doctors who know about infectious
disease in other countries but we do
know I guess we could call it hostility
hostility towards the the medical
community from some state governments
and there's probably more examples that
I haven't mentioned but an important
question and I mean listen auntie VAX
exists in a lot of the world there isn't
you know when we started seeing the the
measles outbreaks as a result of
communities that didn't want to
vaccinate it wasn't just the United
States we have a lot of them in the
United States it wasn't just the United
States when we look at protests to
reopen it's not just the United States
we saw them in isolated spots around the
world but it's mostly in the United
States that we have this phenomenon and
I don't know you know we can make a lot
of broad claims about what it says about
society oh we have the most stupid
people we have the most ignorant
whatever we also have some of the
smartest people and a lot of them a lot
of them but there is something cultural
here where these ideas get a life of
their own media will often give them
oxygen and it's definitely very very bad
here no question about it